you might not recognize Amber Heard as
Mira in Aquaman that bright red hair
isn't her usual look for one thing most
of the time she's blonde and looks much
less like a warrior Merman let's take a
look at the major stepping stones in
amber herds career herd was still in her
teens when North country came out in
2005 and she wasn't featured in any of
the ads or trailers the focus of the
film was Charlize Theron who plays Josey
aimes a female iron worker who takes a
stand against sexual harassment a young
Amber Heard plays the teenage Josie in
some disturbing flashbacks Hurd makes an
impression here despite her lack of
screen time she looks enough like
Charlize Theron to believably play a
younger version of the same character
but she's also already a strong actress
in her own right delivering an effective
performance and some difficult to watch
scenes Hurd was the female lead in
Hidden Palms a 2007 CW series from Kevin
Williamson creator of Dawson's Creek the
show was a team drama about dark secrets
lurking underneath the sun-drenched
surface of an affluent Palm Springs
neighborhood heard played Greta the
mysterious girl next door who's
immediately fascinating to the series
lead but who's also at the center of
several local mysteries the series
received a summer order of eight initial
episodes and was canceled due to low
ratings by the time all eight of air
it's largely forgotten today but it did
raise amber herds profile enough to help
her launch her film career which no
doubt benefited from this show ending
too soon for her to be tied to it never
back down was a teen movie about mixed
martial arts fighting which probably
seemed like a really good idea in 2008
cute on you
[Music]
we're still sweaty it's an extremely
by-the-book plot in which a teenage boy
at a new school must learn to be the
best MMA fighter in order to defeat a
bully and prove himself to all the other
kids
however Amber Heard had plenty to do as
the female lead to the movie she starts
out as the girlfriend of the MMA
fighting bully who tricks the
protagonist into a fight he's not ready
for even in a largely unmemorable movie
it was a showy role for a young actress
like her and it helped launch her into
bigger and better parts pineapple
Express coming right on the heels of
never back down was the movie that
really made Amber Heard a star she plays
a high school senior in an ill-advised
relationship with the movies stoner
process server hero played by Seth Rogen
produced by Judd Apatow and directed by
Andy darling David Gordon Green
pineapple Express was both a hit and a
much discussed comedy of 2008 Rogen and
co-star James Franco were already big
stars but it took at least three
people's careers to the next level Green
himself supporting player Danny McBride
and of course rising ingenue Amber Heard
Hurd had only one scene in the 2009
post-apocalyptic horror comedies zombie
land but it was one of the most
memorable in the movie Jesse Eisenberg's
Columbus explains how he became aware of
the zombie plague when his attractive
next-door neighbor played by Hurd sought
refuge in his apartment after being
attacked by what she thought was crazed
homeless man trying to bite her
naturally Eisenberg wakes the next
morning to find that Hurd has become a
zombie the whole point of her character
here is that she's a basic hot girl who
turns into a monster but Hurd still
somehow takes that premise and makes it
charming and pretty scary
in 2011 Hurd returned to TV but found no
more success this time around than she
did with hitted palms the Playboy Club
was at least splash sheer to start with
a historical drama for NBC about the
women working at the original Playboy
Club in 1961 Chicago heard played Maury
a young woman who becomes a Playboy
bunny shortly after arriving in the city
on the run from a dark past the nature
of Maureen's past was never explored as
it turns out because the Playboy Club
was cancelled after only three episodes
The Rum Diary is another example of
heard taking a pretty typical hot girl
part and making it her own
2011 film by Bruce Robinson was based on
a hunter s Thompson book and stars
Johnny Depp as a down-on-his-luck writer
who takes a job in San Juan Puerto Rico
during the early 1960s Hurd plays a girl
he meets while he's in a boat and she's
skinny-dipping and she goes off to
become the center of a love triangle
between him as shady realtor played by
Aaron Eckhart The Rum Diary is how heard
and depth first met leading to a
relationship that started in 2012 became
a marriage in 2015 and ended in 2016
with heard filing for divorce and
accusing death of domestic abuse all the
boys love Mandy Lane is a slasher style
horror movie about an unusual high
school girl and the secrets she does her
best to keep as the other teens around
her start dying heard played the title
role and it might have been her breakout
part if the movie had come out as
originally planned it was filmed in 2006
before almost everything else on this
list where the 20 year old heard
perfectly cast as the mysterious Mandy
unfortunately the weinstein company
declined to distribute it and the
company they handed it off to went out
of business the movie went unreleased in
the United States for seven years before
finally coming out on video in 2013
after Amber Heard was enough of a star
to get people to watch it the sequel to
2010's machete was not a success at the
box office or among critics but it was
the kind of sequel that made sense for
the over-the-top character played by
Danny Trejo and the unique sensibility
of director Robert Rodriguez the
supporting cast of machete kills
features a parade of beautiful women
Amber Heard is still a standout however
she plays Blanca Vasquez a beauty queen
who's also a secret agent and machetes
handler on his mission to stop a madman
from launching a nuclear missile at
Washington DC interestingly Amber Heard
plays a glamorous government assassin
again in 2014's three days to kill but
in a slightly less outrageous context
the film stars Kevin Costner is a
veteran CIA agent with an estranged
family and terminal cancer heards
younger and more ruthless agent is
tasked with manipulating him into
hunting down one last target by offering
him an experimental cure for his illness
three days to kill is one of those aging
baby boomer action movies where an older
man proves that he still has what it
takes to get the job done
thankfully unlike some movies of this
type the protagonists focus remains on
his family
meaning that herd is never asked to be a
may-december love interest for Costner
2015's Magic Mike XXL was a phenomenon
far more so than the original magic bike
the first movie was a drama about male
strippers
whereas the sequel was a feel-good
celebration of male strippers which
unsurprisingly made it a huge hit among
women as well as gay men and pretty much
anyone who's comfortable watching
muscular men dance with their shirts off
Amber Heard was one of the many fresh
cast members to join for the sequel
playing a new love interest for Magic
Mike played by Channing Tatum at first
her photographer character seems likely
to be a one-night stand but after she
and Mike mutually decided not to have
sex she shows back up later in the movie
and they build more of a relationship
one thing that's clear and looking back
at amber heards career so far is that
she's obviously been chosen for many
roles because of how beautiful she is
however as we've seen again and again
what makes her interesting in those
roles as the intelligence she always
displays adding depth to characters who
weren't necessarily created to havening
check out one of our newest videos right
here Plus even more looper videos about
the DC extended universe are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]